like life-changing yeah like that one in
the sense of giving me something to do
giving me a community of place that I go
to almost on a regular basis every day
for the past half of many years but then
giving me something to think about in a
way of thinking about my life that has
really been helpful in interactions with
people interactions with my environment
giving a wreck on my bike and I took a
really nice for roll off of my bike went
one way I went the other way popped up
and i was completely okay and more than
just being okay I was cooked I was very
calm in the situation the guy who hit me
in the car was completely frazzled but I
was like oh no I'm okay my box okay we
can just go on with our day from here
and I think that's something that I
learned from my Aikido which is a the
reaction and being able to you know use
my body in a way that protects myself
but be being able to keep a calm mind